type it in Chinese cave sounds
my Farmer looking for well
with stone tools no unexplainable type
in unexplainable make sure it's
unexplainable
[Music]
I'm pulling this one up because one of
my mother countries aka the Vietnam
Vietnam man how many mother countries
you got three I think one of the three
what is it China rank them Vietnam Hong
Kong America full oh you can have three
mothers that's impossible two's the max
I think if America is your mother
country you give up the other two huh
damn it you gotta give up one I get
whatever's convenient for me damn it
here we go all right so you can only
have two lesbian matters there's
considered to be what people are sort of
claiming is the eighth wonder of the
world discovered in the crack of a
mountain in Vietnam the Cave the Cave
exactly we gave up wonderful yeah I
wanna you guys want to go I hella want
to check it out my friend's been there
before
they recently like well 20 years ago or
something they found this big [__] off
Cave
it's so big that you can it's like miles
and miles it's just a big and it's got
its own ecosystem it's not just the big
you could fit like Central Park in there
like three times or something no but
like it's a cave within like with like
some of it has sunlight and it's all
like Lake and [__] with animals that
doesn't exist anywhere anywhere else the
animals that don't exist anywhere else
anywhere else yeah they're they're
discovering new species in there because
it's a whole brand new ecosystem that is
cool that is cool yeah it's a nearly
nine kilometer spanning underground
Kingdom lies uh which lies buried deep
in the jungle of central Vietnam known
as sandong uh which translates to
English as English which translates to
English as a mountain river cave it's
the largest cave passage in the entire
world wow whoa basically uh it's got its
own weather system a jungle multiple
lakes and Peaks tall enough to fit like
he said New York City skyscrapers inside
wow
that big it's [__] huge yeah yeah and
then like when you go in there's there's
photos of like there's certain places
where it's like a Cenote where this you
could get the Sun so the sun rays come
through and then it it's like two
ecosystems above and below where the
where the lake is and you can keep going
and there's just like other spots like
that it looks it's hella green right and
you said they only found it because of a
crack
they only found it maybe like 20 years
ago like Joe was saying
um and it's believed to be anywhere from
like two to five million years old wait
they found this 20 years ago I think it
was like something we are late at the
news
I think it was like some farmer or
something it was actually discovered
back in 1991 by a local farmer however
it was only officially explored nearly
20 years after its first discovery in
2000 why'd he tell someone you got to
keep that [__] a secret yeah dude yeah
because isn't the correct thing to not
[__] with it yeah well that's the thing
though because there's obviously there's
two sides of it too because there's a
tourism element because some people know
that a lot of money can be made like
there was even a pitch to build like a
[__] with Long John Silvers type of
situation a cable car oh cool to bring
people through and stuff but again like
when you have has anybody been to halong
Bay
so basically the Ha Long Bay is uh is
what uh they modeled a lot of uh Avatar
after you know like the floating island
scenes and stuff like that it's because
there's a lot of like kind of structures
that kind of float on this Lake Area
it's really beautiful but at the same
time so much tourism has passed through
you can't go like one kilometer in Hong
Bay on your boat without seeing like
trash in the water see that's so sad
yeah so that's sad it's still beautiful
in its Grand Uranus but like in the
details and when you're there you're
still seeing a lot of Tourism that has
like kind of destroyed some of the lands
you know what they need to do is they
need to invite only Japanese tourists
because they'll clean up
like after sports games
yeah yeah that's true
to November let everybody come so
British guys first yeah exactly because
they're gonna get drunk and throw beer
bottles right and then Chinese people
they throw all their lunch left over
keep going down the line and then at the
end in December Japanese people come and
clean up the trash that's nice you think
they'll do that Anthony
I don't even Chinese people are always
gonna pee it all over there
do you have any pictures of it yeah let
me see yeah so here's here's just a
Google search
um because
wow the main places because not all of
it is so big not all of it is like in
sunlight and stuff like that
can you click on one of them so I'm not
looking at like
okay I don't feel like a security guard
at the mall yeah
read that they're [__] Vietnamese
salamander yeah have you seen one of
those
it's called salamando salamander
salamandoma it's like areas like this
bro that's like crazy that looks like
another planet oh dude it's gonna be a
shame that this is gonna get ruined yeah
yeah yeah
I went into a Vietnamese cave that was
really interesting because they um put
like Buddha statues inside of the cave
so you're like in a wet cave and you're
just like this is so weird and then you
hear chanting and they have it sounds
peaceful radio like just playing Auto
like CDs of just chantings yeah and then
there's like a there's like Buddha
statues in there it's like it was really
interesting I don't want tourism in
there it's gonna ruin it people throw
trash everywhere and you got people
selling funnel cakes inside well let's
let's hold on the funnel cakes bomb ever
people sawing Charles inside okay yeah
big turkey legs it's gonna get crazy
somebody's gonna eat all these new
species
Americans at least I don't think it's
gonna be Americans it wasn't as trashed
as other now let's say it uh Southeast
Asian countries it wasn't as trashed so
maybe it was still fresh like not that
many tourisms I bet it's I bet it takes
a lot to get down to those cool spots
over there yeah at this point it's this
is just a random stat it says more
people have summited Mount Everest than
have been through this cave wow that's
[__] cool there's another
um cave in China or a farmer went to go
look for a well and it like opened up
this whole Space right and they found
the ancient freaking cave that they
carved out and there's like steps and
everything and there's like designs on
the wall dude that's scary and then no
one knows how they did it like no one
knows the technology because there's
always aliens it is aliens he never
believes that though because they carved
out of pure Stone
they use stone tools duh Stone and stone
don't work
don't know well wait a minute but it was
are there any like corpses and stuff or
like remaining oh no it was just a big
empty type it in Chinese cave Sounds
by farmer looking for a well farmer with
stone tools no unexplainable
unexplainable make sure it's
unexplainable
figure it out we're trying to maintain
history exactly no that's not it that's
just the case that's an explainable cave
get that [__] out of here no all right
we can't find it that's the one look at
that [__] it was the same one no that's
not the one that's not that although it
doesn't have stalagmites
it can't have stalagmites this is
similar show everybody look your cave is
a cave dude is this cooler than the cave
we were looking at originally yeah this
is cool because it's like it's like
Chinese pyramids but not pyramid schemes
all right so this is one of the photos
because how did they make that how did
they make they're like how do they make
those Ridge lines is that not water
erosion that's pretty crazy
strategic Hydro construction yeah dude
it's ancient it was the Airbender dude
the Avatar that's pretty crazy they said
that we don't have the tools now to
drill into the Rock and make clean lines
like that and carve out a whole system
wow Ryan doesn't believe it either he
thinks it's phony dude nah you know what
I think really happened because back
then you know how like when they made
the great wall they had like a lot a lot
of people right yeah I think they just
got a lot of people to lick the [__] out
of the wall and then with the tongue
yeah
you've got like a a Michelangelo who's
like lying down painting the entire
Sistine Chapel by himself there's got to
be an ability no we still don't know how
that got painted yeah aliens
that's something to think about no they
say that that type of stone is not easy
to go make those clean lines like they
said it's not easy huh it's not they
don't we don't even have the tools today
unimaginable unexplainable so how do
people how do people uh carve Stone now
like this they do like this maybe they
just had those huh
[Music]